[Music]
whirring the gentleman on the pattern
will have quite a bit of very relevant
experience for you so I I think you're
going to enjoy the discussion as we a
background I graduate from the Stanford
Business School in 1997 I have been a
founder of four different entities a
company called optical engineering
making industrial co2 lasers
drugstore.com
good technology newschools venture fund
and also tugboat ventures my most recent
company I've been doing tugboat for the
last four years or an early-stage
venture capital firm moving to the topic
at hand this panel is about idea
evaluation however in conversations with
quite a few of the students over the
years what I hear most often is the
evaluation site is a bit easier the idea
generation side is frankly the harder
part and often find people saying where
the great ideas come from how do you
know you've got a great idea so the
first piece is coming up with a great
idea the second piece trying to
determine the quality of that idea so to
kick off I'd like to have each of the
panelists introduce themselves please
take a minute or so and then if you
could give us your favorite quote I
would be helpful
well I'm Bob fel and I'm I've done a
number of startups and we'll talk about
some of them today I imagine and my
favorite quote actually came from Robert
Kennedy and it was some people asked why
I choose to ask why not my name is Brad
whiskers and I'm the CEO of kinetics
were headquartered in Boise Idaho my
favorite quote is by Julius Caesar
that's vini vidi vici came saw conquered
his report home after defeating after
being victorious in a battle in Asia
Minor after four hours and I like it
because it's tough and B its pithy I
aspire to be as pithy as that so
hi my name is Justin Fisher Wolfson I
graduated from Stanford with master's
computer science an adventure firm
called founders fund which is well known
for investments in Facebook
SpaceX things like that worked in a
variety of startups in the valley and I
don't know my favorite quote which I'm
coming up with off offhand now was
reality has covered my perception but
not changed by it and it reminds me of
when I'm talking to other people what
what to look to look at things to their
eyes I'm Kevin reef co-founder and CEO
of outright calm kind of a late bloomer
this is my first kind of venture startup
run product management a lot of Big
Valley companies over the years my
favorite quote and I'll probably not get
it perfect but it's Thomas Edison when
he talks about some of the biggest
failures in life are people who didn't
realize how close they were to success
before they gave up because I think
perseverance is pretty critical to be a
successful entrepreneur that's great
thank you so diving in my belief is you
have to have a little context around the
importance of an idea before we dive
into the details of how you generate
these ideas and how you evaluate these
ideas so could each of you take just a
moment and give us a sense for how
important do you think the idea is
versus other elements of a successful
business okay we can stop short Bob I'm
going to be first each time today I
guess ok I mention another quote
Edison's quote of its 10% inspiration
and 90% perspiration I think the idea is
important but I think it's not the most
important thing I mean I think that
there are a lot of good ideas but it it
comes down to the implementation of the
idea the management team the passion of
the entrepreneur I mean if you were to
ask me what's most important does the
idea stick with you I mean two days five
days three weeks afterwards are you
passionate about it and I think it's the
passion of the idea and then the
research to really see is there a market
there but I I think idea generation is
good if you read the newspaper and if
you speak to people and if you have a
coterie of friends that are relatively
well-informed and if you have an
international flair you're going to see
a lot of ideas but it's those that stick
with you that you can become passionate
about that you've done the basic
research on that really matter in my
mind I would actually agree with Bob I
don't think that the idea itself is the
primary driver of success a cohesive
team with the ability to execute I think
is more important and I agree that the
passion is very important someone said
it's easier to breathe life life into a
corpse than it is to tame a fanatic and
I think that's true I think if you've
got a passionate team they're going to
work very hard and it's it's easy to
recruit if you have a passionate team
because everybody wants to be part of a
passionate team everybody wants to rally
around morally compelling initiative and
so the idea in of itself is great but
not the most important thing and that
being said I this is coming from a guy
who has a great research team who comes
up with fantastic ideas all the time
that's a pretty big luxury so yeah so
honestly I think ideas are dangerous
what happens is you know people can get
wedded to them you can go down a path
and ultimately this the big success or
failure of the business will be
determined whether or not you're chasing
the right thing so when you have a small
group of people it's an early-stage
company you just want to figure
something out
does the idea matter probably not the
people are way more important because
the number of teams I've seen that have
started in one path and gone a
completely different way six months
later twelve months later and built
something very successful I mean there's
a huge number of those people but
ultimately if you go out and you chase
an idea for a long period of time with a
great group of people that's not very
good it's there's a limit to how
successful you can be and I think
there's a you know it's a question of
where you are in the process that
determines how important important the
idea is yeah so I agree with all these
comments I don't think a great idea is
necessarily going to you know give you
success there are so many other factors
the one caveat is a
at ideas crippling and especially an
idea that's not based on a real need so
there are so many failures out there
where people you know people by nature
we tend to think in terms of solutions
we want to jump to the right answer when
I get a shortcut and so we get wedded to
an idea we get really excited about it
and if it's not grounded in a real need
that a lot of people have a lot of
people that you can reach from a
marketing perspective and get to it's
going to be challenging so there is
something in kind of the early vetting
you need to be honest with yourself
about the idea if you don't get the the
feedback you need to move on and iterate
and change and adapt so yeah so one of
these I want to also share as far as
context I talked to the panel members
before this this is not a discussion
about ideas for companies which you
might sell in a year this is not about
coming up the quick momentum something
that's kind of in the psychist of today
it might be something that you could put
a little money in a little bit of time
and turn around and sell this is really
about how do you build a company could
be a lasting business one that knew
frankly would be viewed as a remarkable
company so it's within that context that
we're talking about idea generation idea
evaluation so if your objective is not
that you know discount some of this
advice because for example building a
great team if you're going to sell the
company in twelve months is really not
that important you might need a great
team of engineers for example is the
technology company but again context I
think is important understand this so
for the gentleman that started companies
where did your idea come from and what
we start Kevin sure so ours started like
many with personal pain so my co-founder
and I we're running a web development
company we'd left kind of big corporate
America and our company outright comm is
free online bookkeeping very basic and
when running our company even though
we'd worked it into it for years trying
to do the finances on QuickBooks when we
were both working at home and needed
access to it it was just painful and we
thought there's got to be a better way
and as we went around and talked to a
lot of our clients and vendors and other
folks we found that there were a lot of
people saying there has to be a better
way and so it started with with kind of
that personal pain but what was
interesting is our original concept that
we put out there
actually threw up mock-ups on the web
and asked people to check it out we
didn't get the reception that we thought
turns out that what people needed the
bigger opportunity the market was
something much simpler and so being able
to listen to the feedback and kind of
change direction and recognizing that
our first premise didn't resonate in the
market was pretty important so I haven't
founded a company but I've been involved
with a bunch of earlier stage startups
both on the operation side and on the
investment side and honestly a lot of it
comes down to finding a pain point I
think the one caution is that people
often find things that are problems for
themselves and not necessarily big
problems so that's that's one thing to
consider a lot of us are consumers we
understand the consumer needs but it
isn't assuming you're solving a big
problem some of the more interesting
companies I've seen you know what about
you know when when I was working in
mobile it was really around you know
what are some of the big problems you
can solve for you know some enterprise
players that you know people have built
relationships with over time and you can
leverage those relationships to find out
what the problems are you know you look
at retailing people have to hit their
numbers every month right you know on
certain products they're huge rebates
you don't necessarily know those things
unless you've been in the industry so
leveraging you know industry knowledge
and places that you've worked or things
like that can add a lot of value I guess
I'd be surprised if anybody in that room
has ever heard of kinetics so I'll give
a little background first kinetics is an
internal incubator we were founded 98 by
internal incubator what I mean is we
have a research team that comes up with
our own ideas and those are the only
ideas that we incubate and we only
incubate those ideas using our own money
we don't have any third party or
institutional backers we are founded 98
we have no debt we have a hundred total
employees well in excess of 300 million
in revenues this year and very very
highly profitable so we've got a lot of
money to do what we need to do in order
and Kubik companies and grow them so we
have two operating subs a lifecycle of a
company in our of a subsidiary with our
company is we have a research phase
where we have a research team that
evaluates that takes any ideas that are
that are members of our company come up
with they've they vet them for
technological or business viability then
we pass them on to our early stage
investment phase where we incorporate we
do all the things we need to do
in order to make the company viable we
have that we have a growth acceleration
phase where we hire a stand-alone
management team to take it to the next
level with an eye to our liquidity event
we had our first liquidity event in in
2000 so we currently have two operating
subs the first is Clickbank which is a
very large online retailer of digital
goods we sell thirty five thousand
titles footers by twelve thousand
vendors we have 2.8 million total
affiliates and our affiliate network we
and over 110 thousand of those
facilitate a transaction in a given
month we do it's a we do 26 thousand
transactions a day so it's a pretty
sizable company and then our second
operating sub is an early stage company
it's in our growth stage it's in our
early stage investment phase right now
it's company called count spelled kou NT
count is an online risk control solution
not just online it's basically
card-not-present risk control solution
the way it came up was with Clickbank
being a retailer of digital goods there
was a lot of we saw a disproportionately
large amount of what are what are called
tests on the internet where people with
stolen credit cards or compromised cards
would try to use it would try to hit
Clickbank in order to see if the cards
were good and though in the brick and
mortar world it's like someone gets your
credit card at a restaurant they take it
to a gas station immediately plug it in
the gas pump because nobody's going to
cuff them and they make sure the cards
so good then they go to Staples or
somewhere by a buy a laptop and fence it
they do that in the online world on
digital goods because they don't have to
put in a bunch of cardholder specific
data there's no shipping address etc so
we saw a lot of the bad guys we were a
test site just like any digital goods
retailer was fortunately our founder has
a PhD in mathematics from Princeton is
and this was his sweet spot his online
risk he actually invented and patented
device fingerprinting which is kind of a
risk control standard in the world right
now and so he came up with solutions we
realized hey we've got this fantastic
solutions a solution that is highly
effective for our for our companies
let's other other online retailers may
have the same be suffering from the same
problems we sent some folks out to do
some analytics and determined it was the
same so as a result of our pain the pain
the
we felt that Clickbank we decided we
could come up with the solution that
work for the rest of the world and it's
been remarkably successful so we're very
fortunate idea evaluation idea Genesis
I'll just go through three companies in
which I have been involved the most
recent is price lock and how it came
about is very simple I had read about
Southwest Airlines having two billion of
its earnings just by hedging its fuel
costs and I I'm involved in a a company
for the benefit of inner school children
a food company and I was across the
street from a commissary filling up at
the gas station and two guys in a Dodge
pickup were arguing over the price of
gas I think this was in 2006 and one guy
said it's going to go up 30% 40% and I
just I don't normally walk over to
people in a gas station but I walked
over to these two guys and I said let me
ask you something
price of dollar 67 on for gas if you
could get a thousand two thousand
gallons you're full gallonage that you
needed for the next few years in pay and
I added a quarter to the price would you
do it and both those guys that
absolutely we do in a segment said how
would you pay for it is that we use our
credit card I said that's 18 percent
money we don't care the price of gas is
going up that much and so it the idea
started to nod me and much to the
chagrin of my wife every time I pull
into a gas station I go over and speak
to people and
and ultimately price lock was born to
extend you know I went I had
relationships at Goldman Sachs and I did
go see them and asked them I learned a
lot about hedging and it was not just
from you know that occasion became a
business but we did our work and we put
together the funding I put my own money
up in the beginning but basically it was
as simple as how do you extend what
Southwest Airlines had done to to to a
whole new class of customers and that's
how price lock was born the second
company I'll talk to you about how the
idea was generated was really premier
radio if you recall and maybe some of
you won't recall in 1994 everyone was
buying radio stations and I was at a
conference much like this the Milken
conference in LA and Sam Zell spoke and
he made this one comment the world is
buying radio stations and an idea went
off in my head I said you know it's
interesting everyone's buying radio
stations why don't I try and get a radio
programmer and build a radio program it
because it's axiomatic when Rupert
Murdoch thought the metro media stations
he wanted form the Fox network if you
own a distribution you want to have the
programming that goes with it
so I try I couldn't buy ABC or CBS I
couldn't afford it but there was a small
company called premier radio which I
bought with a couple people for 33
million dollars and then we just did a
rollup
we bought Jim Rohn sports and Bob Costas
and sports and talk shows the last thing
we bought god-forgive-me was rush
limbaugh but in any event we did do that
and we became the largest radio
programming company in the world and we
sold it
somebody ran'l now for 498 million
dollars so it was not a bad deal
the last idea that I want to talk about
was an idea that in my mind we did too
quickly and we did it we've got you
friends at Kleiner Perkins but you
probably know it silicon gaming the I
had been involved in Electronic Arts and
with Brooke Byers in the startup and I
said and I was standing in Las Vegas
of Steve Wynn and he said you know it's
not going to always be the blue-haired
ladies that play these machines and all
of a sudden I said Jesus you know we
have this touch technology you have so
much we've learned from the game
business why don't we put a group
together and why don't we create a
company and we did create silicon gaming
with the whole idea that silicon game we
would have the new type saut machine
that it would not be just this static
you know press the button and watch your
money what we built the company we put a
lot of money into it we had but we had a
heck of a product but what I didn't
really do and this is goes to the you
know an idea as only as good as its
implementation what I didn't really
learn and I did hire Andy Pascal Steve
Wynn's nephew who ran the slot machine
business for at that time MGM Mirage but
I didn't realize that it doesn't matter
how good or bad the machine is it just
matters can you get in location people
go there and they play the Machine and
it doesn't matter you can have beautiful
graphics you've just spent a lot of
money it's get me something that works
quickly because the odds are all the
same anyhow so we sold it we built a
company we got our money out with maybe
a little bit of profit not not if you've
count time and we sold the company to
igt which is the largest in the
slot-machine business so I come back to
our original point ideas are only as
good as they were implementation and the
work you do to make sure that the market
is big enough and you can build a profit
business there from thank you so going
from specific I'd like to ask you now
about and it and Bob I think you gave a
few and Justin you give a few also but
any other thoughts on strategies for
coming up with ideas how do you go out
in the world tomorrow say the four of
you or starting fresh tomorrow and
you're like I'm gonna go build a big
company I want to be a meaningful
remarkable company I want it to matter
what would you do tomorrow to start
looking for ideas anybody can take that
one we're not to go in order
four sons that you know two marriages
going from you know 29 down to two seven
years old and you know I look at the
world of Education and I see you know
just generally China going to school 30%
more Korea going to school 30% more and
if I were to start a company tomorrow
the general area of education would have
huge appeal to me I don't know what it
would be but I mean I think there's a
lot of Asian opportunities education
space I also think there are
opportunities in quantified health I
mean there's much of their bunch of
interesting that change that are
happening with sensors today but I mean
maybe the broader question is you know
how would you go about starting a
company because I think first off it's a
question of what you're passionate about
so maybe your passion about health care
maybe your passion about education you
know if you're not don't worry about it
right there's there's the general sense
of if you want to build big businesses
if you want to build lasting businesses
something that will be a great
enterprise you're looking for the
subsets of opportunities that can be
billion-dollar companies and that's not
all companies right there there are lots
of very successful small businesses that
drive most of the employment as I've
heard on the radio consistently in
America so I mean there are lots of
great businesses that you can do but if
you want to build a billion-dollar
multi-billion dollar company that has a
real impact on a lot of people that's a
small subset of businesses and so you
have to think big and you have to
understand where there's a big problem
in a big market
I think there's within that a subset of
businesses that are easy right so going
back to your point about you know
distribution right you know you're
trying to get slot machines on the floor
distribution in almost all businesses is
a pretty big challenge so the question
is you know some some ways are easier
than others and some might be specific
to your background and your
relationships so that's that's kind of
what I would start by thinking about so
how do what's billion-dollar business
and then what's an easy billion-dollar
business and one way to think about that
is to think about what kinds of
businesses tend to be winner-take-all so
places where you have some kind of
network effect right you've got all the
classic communications networks things
like that you've got Facebook all the
phone companies like these are these are
quintessential network effects
businesses when there's a winner
there's
in winter and it's a big one right you
can look at places where you have an
information asymmetry companies like
Google they have a better product
because they have way more data on
whatever one is doing to refine the
results so they've consistently just
stayed ahead of the curve of everyone
else because they continue to have more
and more data so I think there are some
general themes that you can take
advantage of when you're just trying to
think up what are the really really big
idea is that you can chase down on the
high level question I'd go to lunch and
by that I mean I get the smartest people
that I know which are generally
fortunately people that are on my team
and I'd take them to sushi and this is
what we generally do we go to sushi we
sit at a sushi restaurant in Boise and
yes we have those for a landlocked state
and we go to the same place and we sit
at the same table and we start
brainstorming and we'll brainstorm for a
few hours will identify some problems
and then we'll start identifying
plausible solutions and that will
usually carry over into our research lab
where we sit in front of a whiteboard
with you pick your drink dr. pepper for
one of them Red Bull for another and
water for me fortunately because I've
got to have to have the cooler head to
prevail by the end of the discussion and
we usually start then refining the ideas
of okay that's a fantastic solution
although it's going to take us three
years to develop what's the good enough
element to that solution that can get us
into the game and the ones we come up
with that solution then we start
evaluating okay is that scalable and is
it and then we start evaluating alright
and are we going to make any money at it
and then we start asking people who are
the potential customers and there's no
there's no better way to ask them than
just to sit them down and ask them which
is what we've done with ours is this a
solution that you'd be interested in
what are the bells and whistles that
you'd need to add and then you keep
going back to and can we do that is it
scalable can we do it with a relatively
small number of people and and make
relatively large numbers doing it so
when we want to find a solution when we
want to have our next idea when we want
to vet our next idea we just go to lunch
yep in Boise in Boise that's it
that's like that's a good restaurant yes
your business I think you do a good job
yeah she plays rah rah rest
in Boise Idaho is the birthplace of many
many good eyes so I'm kind of a fan of
Bob's story about going up and talking
people at gas stations so for me I find
it hard to say I want to go out and come
up with ideas and it's more about making
sure you're good at listening every day
in every interaction you have with other
people because ideas get thrown by you
every single day you read about it you
hear about it and it's just are you
paying attention and every once in a
while something you know this gets back
to the passion comment when you hear
something that you're like okay that
interests me that intrigues me that's
probably going to catch some of your
internal passion and you'll probably
stick with it so then go out and do some
more research talk to more people read
up on it and see if you kind of get that
validation is things support your
hypothesis and sometimes you're going to
find that not you're wrong okay move on
to something else but a lot of it is and
a lot of the entrepreneurs I know
they've got a backlog of ideas I've got
10 15 things that they would love to
work on right now except they're working
on something that I think is their best
idea and if that stops they'll move on
to the next one so you know a lot of
folks I've got a list you know on my
laptop actually up on the web on
backpack of the things one day I want to
get to you know after this company
what's the next thing I'm going to
tackle and it's always coming up and so
I think a lot of it is just being very
aware and recognize the different data
points as they come across your path to
start drawn those connections that maybe
other people don't see and then you
start investing the time to really go
validate is there a big market there can
I reach these people can i you know
derive most of the economic benefit from
it so I think this is a good transition
point because there's been whether it be
over sushi or they'll be walking down
the street in every interaction whether
it be you're talking to other folks
around Stanford going to the gas station
how do you guys feel about the the
discussion of your ideas with other
people do you feel like you have to hold
it close to your vest or do you feel you
can open it up or how do you think about
that I mean you're probably not blogging
about your best idea before you start it
but you know I would haven't you advise
people and in in that spectrum of I'm
not talking to anybody because I
want anybody to know what I'm doing
because it's just such a great idea
it'll get copied to your posting a blog
post saying here's my idea I think it's
greatest in the world can you beat me to
it so what would you guys say
I'll start I think one of the most
common mistakes and I've made it many
times is you think your idea is amazing
and if anybody else hears that they're
going to rip it off it's not true if
it's a really great idea and it's really
innovative most people who hear are
going to tell you you're an idiot
because conventional wisdom but like the
really big opportunities tend to be when
most people don't see it so the really
good ones are you're going to say it and
a lot of people say that's just stupid
so for example I don't know if it's
going to be successful but I find blippi
fascinating right sharing your credit
card spending I cannot think of a
start-up in the last like five years
where I've heard more people say that's
most idiotic thing I've ever heard and
yet people are doing right and why and
one of our investors was just at our
board meeting the other day telling me
about the benefits he uses and he you
know he built this relationship with
another entrepreneurs like that's
fascinating to me so that's one of those
things where I'm pretty sure they could
have shown it to ten people and they
would have said come on don't do that
that's crazy
plus the whole point about executing you
have a great idea and everybody can have
the same great idea but it's the team
that out executes the others who really
refines that idea gets in market and
proves it that's going to win so you
know yet you don't blog about it but you
know we had mock-ups of our original
vision up on the web you know two years
ago two and a half years ago showing
exactly what we were going to build and
yet we have a lot of competitors that
we've kind of blown by since then
because they look you know they could
have seen it they looked at it and they
didn't think we were right well we kind
of turned out to be right I kind of
build on Kevin's point because I think
if you talk one I think there's really
no reason not to share with people I
mean whether or not you put it out on
the internet and you know you do much
SEM so that way lots of people find out
about it is a different story but
functionally talking to people in
general gets you good feedback and if
it's a really great day you're going to
get two responses that's a terrible idea
why the hell would I ever do that or wow
that's the best idea I've ever heard can
I join you
right people in general the responses
while that's the greatest idea I've ever
heard let me go try and do the exact
same thing and build another team over
here that that's a very uncommon
uncommon response so in general it's I
think it's worth talking to people the
you know the the interesting the
interesting thing about sharing ideas is
one it's great way to recruit people
right like you you want to be able to
build the best team and so you need to
be able to tell a story that's
compelling that you can that you can
attract the best kinds of people and so
I think telling that story to other
people will force you to build a concise
clear vision of what you're trying to do
and I think that's that's a very
important part of the process and quite
frankly most people don't do anything
you could go out I mean there are lots
of great ideas lots of very successful
companies in many respects we're pretty
obvious and I'm not a big fan of
intellectual property but I mean the
issue with most of these companies isn't
that they're that hard they're not
necessarily that difficult to do but you
could have told a million people and
only seven of them would have even tried
so I mean functionally it's that people
don't take the first steps to go and
build something right and there's a lot
of perfectly reasonable excuses for not
doing it but in general people just
don't take the first step and that's and
that's the big reason why lots of
perfectly huge businesses get built and
you wonder why there weren't 47 other
people chasing them down I agree with
Justin and Kevin we to some degree we
have a very aggressive trade secret
protection program in place and that's
because particularly the industry that
counts in well let's actually click link
as well
we've been shamelessly plagiarized a lot
of times the differentiator is that we
execute quickly we have a scrum shop
with with two-week sprints and we get
things done and we get them done quickly
and efficiently but people do
shamelessly plagiarize good ideas so we
have a good trade secret protection
program we don't really let go of our
secret sauce but we do go out and talk
to people about our ideas because that's
a that's the best way to find out how
good your idea is you may think it may
solve as someone else said earlier it
may solve a pain that you're currently
suffering but you don't know if you're
you're just particularly bad at what you
do so your pains far worse than anybody
else's so
you might want to you might want to vet
that a little bit so we were kind of
right in the middle we protect our trade
secrets but then we come up with
speaking points that we can talk to
other people about so they can't figure
out exactly what we're going to do but
tells them enough so we can get good
input so when we go to market we've
optimized the likelihood of success to
sign an NDA you know so I'm a former
lawyer I'm a recovering lawyer yeah so
and and our team at Fenwick and West
probably kill me for saying this but you
know it depends on the nature of the
beast but a lot of times you don't and I
don't know exactly how good those are
anyway because every PE you ever talk to
signs an NDA but then they go off and
somewhere along Sand Hill Road
everything everybody knows everything
about everything every other company
because they go out and grab a cocktail
together so I don't know exactly how
effective they are there are instances
when we do and there's a lot of
instances when we don't we're just very
careful about what what we disclose that
nobody can invent our secret sauce
we're not posting source code perhaps
you're right what you're talking about
is technical I mean you you build
technical barriers that are sort of not
obvious to till you know you go on tell
some of what your business is and the
problems that you're solving it's a high
level things it's hard to reverse
engineer that buttress by a healthy
patent portfolio and them and all you're
doing by shamelessly polarizing us is
providing us with a revenue opportunity
so history that's the formal lawyer
talking yeah I'm just gonna book a table
at the sushi restaurant next is raw I
think it's broad next I've never
protected an idea I found that the more
I I talked to people and the more
responses I get the more refined the
idea becomes and the better I am at
articulating it thereafter and I think
over time we all develop a coterie of
friends and sounding boards who you know
maybe there's a half a dozen people whom
you always go to and you talk to about
ideas and I know in Santa Barbara every
Sunday morning at least during the
football season a group of guys and I
have breakfast and you know probably bet
more than we discuss ideas but you could
develop a group of people with whom you
you feel comfortable telling your ideas
and they give you honest open feedback
and I think that I've never tried to
protect an idea because I've always
thought if I want to do it I'll try and
do it with the best management team of
anyone and you know maybe it's a
confidence but that's that's where I
stand so how about the common mistakes
in evaluating an idea where have you or
your friends kind of ran into trouble
Bob you were kind enough to share the
story of silk in gaming sound like you
kind of missed the behavioral aspects of
that in the importance location but can
you share some other examples were or
would kind of illustrate common mistakes
that are made I you know I I've stayed
with some ideas too long and just
because you know I was passionate about
them but not realistic you know we we
looked at the restaurant business 1992 I
think it was and I said why is there not
a casual Chinese like PF Changs
and I did you know I did get with Philip
Chang and I did do a couple of
prototypes and I kept saying we just
don't have it right well you know
several million dollars later we still
didn't have it right so it was it was a
mistake just stay with too long and but
listen to my wife no truly I mean she
said you know this food is terrible I
mean she was very blunt about it and I
kept saying I Brent yeah which is
absolutely true I mean it basically you
I said but it's authentic its authentic
and that you know I was I was passionate
about that part of the world and I was I
was wrong
the second mistakes that I've made or
with you know and sometimes I'm so
anxious to proceed that I pick the
management by background and not by how
well will I get on with them it's a hard
thing to really figure out you you you
you pick someone because God what a
great background go back to this this
guy ran all of the restaurants for you
know for meri Corp and a big chain I'm
just using one example but the guy could
not be an entrepreneur I mean he you
know he had to have five people if he
told a small story and so I urge anyone
who's going to be an entrepreneur and
build a management team spend a lot of
time with the people you're going to
hire get to know them better than the
mistakes I've made it not doing that
enough in certain instances and and and
and you just get mesmerized by someone's
background as opposed to do it do they
do they fit with you it's ok we'll do
you promise so you're spending more time
with them what are you trying to get
underneath in those discussions would I
want to go a ball game with this man or
woman would I want to spend time with
their family I mean it's just it it
takes time to get to know someone and it
is good in a start-up there's going to
be the bad times and do you want this
person in the trenches with you there's
going to be the bad times you're going
to you know I I can remember certain
times where I thought you know I'm not
going to make payroll and there's going
to be bad times and would this person
really just say forget about paying me
or stuff like that I it's that I've made
mistakes and we all have I'm sure any
people forget that the only reason
companies go out of businesses they run
out of money like at the very
fundamental level the only reason you
you you stop running your business is
because you've run out of money
in the world of startups money equals
time right more money you have more cash
to have in the bank the more time you
have to build your business and that's
just the fundamental nature of the game
so you know the question I think the
biggest mistakes that people tend to
make is they somehow get the timing
wrong
I mean timing turns out to usually be
one of the most important things with
any business and if you know you're
right and people have been saying mobile
as the place to be in the 80s well you
know start your mobile company in the
80s probably not around today started in
the 90s probably not around today
started in 2002 probably not around
today right so functionally it's
question of you know how much time do
you have to build your business and if
you get it wrong if you if it turns out
that you thought it was a
direct-to-consumer business but you
actually actually have to go and strike
big distribution deals with you know
major companies that take 24 months to
do you know that's that's money and so
people you know I think one of the
biggest mistakes you can make is not
understanding the amount of capital it
takes to build the business into a
sustainable point once you have a
sustainable business the world is very
different but a lot of startups
especially around this this area you
know they're they're not they're not
started in a sustainable way right it
takes time to get there and you have to
make sure to have enough cushion that if
you're wrong
you still have a chance to get there
because if you're off by six months it
doesn't matter all right I agree with
both just an EM Bob I think yes the
question was common mistakes mine would
be probably letting the fervor of
creating an exciting cool solution be
the driver without properly sizing the
market or proper properly evaluating
your end consumers needs I see that a
lot even in our shop when our research
team when they start working on a
project we get really excited about
something's really cool I mean this is
just a fantastic idea and what we have
to do with the model that we've created
we have to be really disciplined we can
take it a long way we've developed
products and been pretty close to being
ready to go to market and had to say
okay we've put a lot of time and energy
into this thing is this the right move
for us right now and you have to be
really willing to put your pride aside
and say you know what we may not have we
may not have evaluate
that quite properly so we're going to
fold it pull the plug now because we
want to be around tomorrow and we don't
want this to be a huge drain and you've
just got to be really disciplined about
that and it takes a lot of pride to be
able to say yeah we were wrong on this
one next one we're going to nail so did
you ever have one where you felt in your
gut that it was wrong but you went ahead
and launched it and then learned that
your gut was right
fortuitously no we haven't we haven't
done that yet there's been ones where in
my gut when we started the development
process that I thought wow this is this
is I don't know I don't see the full
vision yet but I but you know we're all
we've all we all think it's got
potential and as we as it evolved as we
got closer to launch we didn't that this
isn't the right move so we've been
fortunate enough to pull the trigger and
cut things off before we've gone to
market so can I ask a follow-up question
John suppose we bred some people would
argue that if you have a lot of very
smart analytical people sitting around a
table which may be what your research
lab is maybe it's not I don't know that
contrarian ideas the ones that are the
non-obvious ideas will never make it
through the table because there's too
many people can shoot down any contrary
an idea so high because you do have
contrary night you've done things that
other people pry density is obvious
right so how do you manage that so that
the the analysts don't crush it well I
mean accepted more broadly like your
friends who are analysts your friends
who are good consultants and bankers and
all that here you might be bouncing your
ideas off it just can't see why you want
to go after that stupid idea well
there's a lot of things first of all we
all recognize that whenever we start
these discussions we have to be open
honest and fearless
I want people that come up with
contrarian ideas because it to the rear
they're not coming throwing those out on
the table we're going to we're going to
make mistakes that we didn't have to
make and we're going to spend money that
we didn't have to spend in order to
figure out those mistakes so I think
we've worked together enough that we
understand what each other's strengths
and weaknesses are and we're able to to
factor that in at this point as we've
been we've been successful at what we've
done because sometimes we recognize yeah
he's got a good point there but there's
also this proclivity that he has
you know not necessarily like this sort
of idea and we're able to call each
other out on those things and so somehow
we make it work just by being very very
open very honest and communicating we're
probably if you ask one of my CEOs we
communicate too much here's the side of
not talking so much but I'm I'm the dr.
Phil of the business world I guess
so we we just know each other we work
through them and we and we and if people
have legitimate concerns we we we drive
we drill down on them so have you ever
pushed against the entire team or had a
subset of the team push against the
entire team to move an idea forward oh
yeah I mean of course so you carry the
big baseball bat uh there's a few big
baseball bats so there's there's more
than one but because what a dynamic
psychologists share context some of the
firms I worked at it often be a partner
who said I really believe in this idea
it may be the sixth search engine in the
world it may be two guys that are very
young they don't seem that complete
perspective on what it takes to build a
business but with this is going to be
huge and the other partners say now we
don't want to be in the sixth search
engine it's the technology is not that
differentiated the core technology is
very similar the technology and the
existing search engines what do we
really have here and then one person
sometimes just puts it down
they just say work I just have to do
this so I was always trying to bring it
out we've had those situations ok so at
the end of the day the buck stops here
so sometimes I can hear the call yeah
sometimes I got to make the call so but
it's we've got a healthy we get into
some healthy debates which is actually a
lot of fun in the other common mistakes
so I would say you know two most common
mistakes I see one is what everybody's
talked about which is you tend to get
locked in the solution you know you
don't you don't believe the data that
comes back that says this idea that you
think is awesome isn't so awesome that's
really easy to do we all get attached to
things we love so doing that the other
one I want to talk about is one of
things really hard the early stage is
just maintaining folk
because you're going to have so much
data going on here you know you can only
do so many things getting distracted is
very easy to do chasing shiny objects
and new opportunities there it's because
when you start it's pretty rare that you
know the ultimate answer when you start
you're going to get there it's going to
be a journey but it's very easy to get
too far off course and especially if you
know if you're chasing money if you're
chasing a big deal these things like
that it's very easy to do and so you
know time and resources are precious and
limited so kind of focus and ruthless
prioritization are pretty important it's
very easy to get distracted so how do
you balance it because I like to think
of that early formation stage as honest
being this drunkards walk you're in this
process the discovery you talk to one
guy at the gas station he says one thing
that's discouraging you talk to another
guy the gas - does do something
different and then you talk to your
buddy and says oh I have this friend
that knows how to do these exchanges you
should start building the idea how do
you know how much you kind of need to
leave a little bit right back and forth
ideas discussion so are you talking
about post that phase we've decided it
you're going to go is it through so so
there are certain things where you know
if you're getting conflicting data you
just need to invest more time to go you
know find art and are you looking at the
data the proper way right are you not
are you missing something you know
you're you think you're on found the
root cause but you're really looking at
the symptom and you just need to dig and
maybe get some more data points but I
think the bigger risk is actually once
you get beyond that you start there are
some short-term pressures around timing
and maybe milestones that you need to
hit that some opportunities may present
themselves and say you know what I can I
can demonstrate more progress in the
short term but that might take me off
course a little bit and it's a constant
trade-off of what am I trying to get to
versus what can I do today tomorrow you
know what can give me a little bit of
money or a little bit of runway but it's
not quite core to what we're trying to
do don't know that there's an easy
answer on how to do that but I think
it's one of the biggest risks in terms
of things to watch out for talk a little
bit about the risk of you've got a
contrary an idea and now you hit it on
this Kevin and you're walking up a Down
Sand Hill Road and
they don't see it so you just pull a
color on how you feel about that would
you
literally walk away from money
completely bootstrap at $20,000 a year
salary would you give up at that point
well how would you respond to that well
given that I thought about giving up
maybe five six times before we actually
got our money the first time that's a
challenge I mean it's tough we did
bootstrap it but everybody has a
different risk profile right you may not
have $20,000 that you can afford and
I've been working on the valley and been
well compensated I could afford to do it
for a little while but if you're not in
that situation everybody's got to make a
personal choice of you know for your
situation you know how passionate are
you do you believe this and a lot of
times you know we had a lot of people
pass on us the first time and then we
had a lot of term sheets on our second
time so we were able to prove some
people wrong but you're going to find
that a lot of people are not going to
believe in your idea that's why my
favorite quote is it's about
perseverance it's about are you willing
to stick with it
you are going to screw up a lot of stuff
you make a lot of mistakes but if you
view those as the best opportunities to
learn and get better so that you know
eventually you'll figure it out and
you'll show the traction and the money
will come find you if I guess my advice
would be if you can't get the money
early on or you can't convince folks go
prove it in market because if your idea
is legit you'll be able to prove it in
market and once you do that you'll get a
lot of believers so that's one other
question which kind of struck me as we
were talking is you guys keep talking
about the importance of the team when
you're at the early phases of idea
generation and idea evaluation do you
want to have a co-founder with you doing
that or a couple co-founders and if you
do what kind of people would you
recommend be there at that time because
you don't know exactly where it's going
to all go do you any comments on that
standpoint
you you want someone who understands the
business that you're going into pretty
well you want someone who's compatible
and you want someone who is cut of the
cloth of the entrepreneur who can take
adversity well to your point about
perseverance sometimes you make mistakes
in the beginning you recast but I I
thank you it's from my standpoint in my
standpoint no it's easier to have a
partner so you'd rather not be alone
Eagle figure it all out yourself and
then find the right partner for that
particular business the first deal I
ever did I was five percent and someone
else was ninety five percent and he
called me partner and I learned
something from that because it it gave
me the feeling that I was really with
him and I and taught me the value of
treating people with respect and as if
they were partners even though it was
ninety five five emails touch up still
for me you know I couldn't write code
well enough to start a software company
so I definitely needed some someone to
partner with so there was a necessity
there but what I've learned over time so
my co-founder and I get along very well
not because we have the same mindset but
because we have very complementary
mindsets
he's a very even-keeled person and I'm
like this like Steve Ballmer I get
really frustrated and then I get really
excited and he's there to balance me and
he's got a great technical mind and good
product Sensibility so if you are going
to get a partner it is agree with Bob
but you want to know that person really
well because there a lot of stuff will
go wrong and it's you know the classic
lines about you find out what people are
really like when stuff goes wrong you
want to make sure you are in the
trenches with somebody who believes in
the vision is committed and can react
well to adversity and move and be
creative and did you deeply reference
check your co-founder I got to work with
him so we both came out of the same
company that was your deep yes reference
checking was yeah we both found that
neither one
could get along with large company life
anymore so we had same passion for going
and creating stuff anything else
I just basically like getting married to
people right if you're if you're gonna
have a partner it's not a it's not you
know it's not a fling right this is
something that's gonna you're going to
be in for a long time
to the point of you want to know that
the person you're getting involved with
is someone that you want to be involved
with for a long period of time I think
the you know the issue is with one
person it's kind of hard to heart it's
kind of hard to have a conversation and
you know having having another person
you can you can have a constructive
conversation and you can get to a better
outcome
now this there's a there's a breaking
point to this three people okay you know
four people five people six people I
mean it starts to get to the point where
it's unmanageable so you know there's
probably could cut off around three you
know two is probably better than one but
you know one is definitely better than
four so you know that it's good to be
able to have a conversation I think
that's important when you're starting
something super yeah I agree it's hard
to have an idea rich environment if it's
you so even if you have the big stick
yeah Mattox cobbler is or how great your
ideas are but uh but I agree that the
key with them with Bob and Kevin of
bolsa which is the key is make sure
you've got somebody that Bob said
earlier you're gonna want to be able to
go to a baseball game with you don't
have to agree all the time in fact you
probably don't want the person you're
always going to agree with is your
partner but you better make sure you can
you can handle having sushi with them
regularly that's great okay so another
thing I think is important because we
talked about kind of the team your
network outside personal life just
having other people who are supportive
is going to be pretty important too
especially when stuff goes wrong so you
know having a wife that will tell you
that you're nuts or having friends that
will tell you to keep believing that you
know don't give up this is I mean this
is just true in business in general
having other people to believe you and
support you
is more important down the road than it
probably appears when you start so thank
you so I'm going to open up to questions
in just a couple of minutes but I want
to do any of you guys just have a
burning thing you want to say given that
we've had this discussion like that
which David asked that question or I
need to get this out anything you want
to say before we move to questions don't
give people a chance to think about
questions I'd like to ask V entrepreneur
requires you to be irrational to a
certain extent because it is marginally
an irrational
irrational I think it's marginally
insane to go out and try and start a
company with nothing right and this is
this is a difficult process lots of
things will go wrong everyone will tell
you that there's a high likelihood of
failure the statistics bear that out so
you have to be marginally insane to do
that and the people that are the best
are the ones that can somehow balance
the fact that you know they'll take all
the data that says this is a terrible
terrible idea and throw it out and say
no it doesn't matter it actually is a
great idea and they'll be right some of
the time and you don't also have the
flexibility to get it back and know that
it you know it I need to stop this I
need to go do something else and that's
an impossible thing from anyone sitting
on a panel to figure out we know which
way which which time is the right time
to pick that path but that's I mean
that's really what it those are the
ultimately successful entrepreneurs and
it's a really hard thing to do it does
get back to that passion thing you know
you have to have the fire inside to deal
with all the stuff that's going to
happen because if it's just an academic
exercise if it's just you know I I want
this great business when things get hard
you need something else to hold on to
you need to really really want it
believe in it
whether it's anger that's driving you or
just frustration whatever it takes to
motivate you to really want to make this
happen that's probably the number one
thing I've heard from every investor
when they evaluate let me talk about
passion it's you know they want to see
that they want to see that fire that
will just will wheel it to success it's
a lot of work I mean it's cold spot work
you know your your your know we have
great resources backing our startups but
it's still a lot work you're still going
to your first customer and they're like
all right where are your references well
you can call my mom she thinks I'm great
also there's a couple other guys that I
hang out with regularly but you know
it's it's a lot of work to break through
with with a start-up right you know I
said this to my oldest son few weeks ago
you if you find something for which you
really have a passion you'll never work
a day in your life and its really true
if you really have the passion I mean my
best definition of an entrepreneur is
someone who has no other choice
you know it's just what you want to do
that's great so short hands how many
questions out there
one two three about nine we've got 15
minutes so we're going to get through
all these we need to do some about a
minute and a half so we just ask your
question and if I can ask the panelists
who ever look at each other and if
something thinks it's theirs grab it and
then if you have one add-on comment but
let's not go through all four people is
that okay great it's good it makes it
easy for us
everything was interesting but
intentionally evaluation really you came
back
on the knee but the market and so on
okay now investors typically are focused
on the business model and as everyone
knows a lot of very successful
businesses have been built on an absence
of initial revenue so that's major issue
I think that when you're zero are faced
with that problem there is a need but
the cost of this user the cost of
marketing whatever network research be
so by that I mean the hem arena as well
get it for free and hope that the
inclusion rate Sunday some viable
business some evaluation on the
viability of the business model is
something which I'd like you know it's
good thank you I mean so functional II I
agree with you I think that's why
venture capital exists right I mean if
there if there wasn't someone to give
you money to run a business and give all
your product away for free you know it
like that's that's what makes the valley
run that's that's what's made a run for
four years I think Kevin's point of his
experiences are very true though you can
go out there you can have an idea people
you know people don't buy into it until
you get market traction right and then
and then you know it's a completely
different investment and so from an
investment standpoint you know if you're
if you're talking about making really
early-stage investments I say I don't I
wouldn't care I don't care about the
idea that much I care about the people I
want to see two or three people who are
incredibly passionate about something
who work well together and are going to
go figure it out and like I said I've
invested in many of those teams they've
come up and done completely different
things six months later and that's great
that's actually in some sense what you
want to have happen but if you're going
through you know if you're if you're
going through and trying to solve that
distribution problem yeah I mean it once
you get market traction there has to be
a business it has to has to work right
there has to be a model that makes sense
and I think that just kinda depends on
where you are on the on the time line of
going through that you know building
that company anybody else wants about
business model
I think if you're talking about really
early stage investment where you're
writing a yeah I think it completely
depended it may not matter at all right
I mean you could have looked at even if
you looked at Google back you know when
they were out doing you know shopping
their Dell it wouldn't matter like
Facebook it wouldn't have mattered but
there was still a long-term concept of
you know where you where you thought you
could probably get money but it wasn't
you could still build very valuable
businesses without without that I mean
YouTube was very valuable business and
you know today it's it's a very
successful division of Google but they
didn't make money especially for years I
guess I think different venture
capitalists have very different opinions
about this and if you are a consumer
internet investor venture capitalist and
you understand media business models you
may be much more comfortable saying I
don't care about revenues because you
can get to hundreds of millions of
eyeballs we know how to monetize those
somehow versus on the enterprise side
you're not going to get that at all if
you go to somebody in touch Kalp say
look we're going to actually give
hardware and software to enterprises for
free and we'll figure it out later
they're going to say you're crazy you
know you have to have a business more
you're selling to enterprises because if
you sell something because I'm going to
free to the enterprise often they put no
value on you have no commitment from the
enterprise itself because the cost of
that is much more than just the cost of
the software so I think there's a real
innovation and how enterprise software
is being done today because people are
taking the channels that have worked on
the consumer internet a lot of the vital
channels spreading it through the
enterprise then going back to the
enterprise and asking them for money
later right so I mean I think they're a
pom computing room others did the exact
same thing there's current consumer
entry points but keep moving on I think
you're gonna have to be very careful
about who you talk to and understand the
bias of those venture capital firms
because that people have different
tolerances for that so okay Kevin you
mentioned the importance of user
feedback early in validating an idea
give any advice for the best mate
get users in front of it is it mock
website yeah the cheapest fastest way
you can do it
so is it trying to think is it can my
real name of the author wrote a book
called don't make me think we talked
about our tendency to want to overthink
kind of especially with from an academic
mindset how we do research the most
important thing about research is do it
quickly show it to somebody who is even
a reasonable proxy for your target
customer and do it with paper on the web
you know HTML mock-ups even if it's
conversations napkins you know gas
stations throw ideas out there the most
important thing is just get some early
feedback from some potentially
prospective customers because you know
you'll get more feedback in the first
iteration from three to five people to
then go modify the idea so it's more
important to kind of iterate quickly
than it is to put together like the
perfect research project or get the
right prototype and you know that it's
just early data is better than like the
perfect data later after the
investigation
yeah I think it it's going to depend on
the idea so they're definitely pleased
that we have first mover advantage but
there are I think a lot of ideas out
there tend to be an iteration on
somebody else has already tried it and -
I think most of the points people have
made it's not necessarily the idea it is
about the execution so fast follower
works really well if you see somebody do
it they're just not doing it quite right
we're actually following there was a
company to try to do exactly we're doing
built too complex a product approach the
market in the wrong way they got into a
switching game and we looked out and we
said that's you know very similar vision
for what we wanted to do when we
disagreed with their tactics and we came
in so we were not the first ones with
this idea
I actually don't think that I've been
creating any business is hard and so in
some sense you know building the biggest
business possible isn't significantly
more risky than building a smaller
business I mean they're there you know
there's some nuance there but the
difference between running a you know a
company that's 500 million you know
valued at $500 a billion dollars is not
substantially different right I mean
that there are there a lot of you know
there are differences but in some sense
you want to you want to go after the
biggest possible idea because a lot of
the challenges you're going to see in
terms of building the team and
distribution things like that they're
sort of constants right and they only
they scale literally whereas other
things don't scale literally they're
exponential so the best thing you can do
is non Trentino yourself real
don't-don't-don't BS yourself know
yourself know your real capabilities
that's the hardest thing yes have a
grand vision but know who and what you
can do and that takes a while but it's a
very important factor in success I live
one bit that if you're going to take a
bold strategy like that you better have
an angle you better understand something
nobody else understands and go after it
because we'll use Google as an example
when they were getting started
they knew Yahoo they knew Inc to me they
knew Alta Vista and they knew the limits
of those businesses and they were
absolutely convinced that they were not
committed to innovating and search and
other people on the server side way you
know excites were seven billion dollars
out of homes were 15 billion dollars Inc
Tamizh work twelve billion dollars
they're going to keep innovating forever
you'll never catch them is like that
isn't what was happening inside those
companies they had stopped so
cheapskate cashflow you willing to work
insane hours and surround yourself with
other people who are as well great all
for hit that one talk to a lot of people
people are always willing to that's a
topic that people will talk ad nauseam
about and get a lot of input there's
there's all kinds of benchmarks
depending on the industry but there's no
substitute for bending a lot of people's
here and saying how'd you do it what are
you doing what are you taking and I tell
people all the time I'd rather own five
percent of a hundred million dollar pie
that 100 percent of a 1 million dollar
pie so a lot of people don't don't ever
figure that out yeah I think that's
actually the biggest risk and hear that
a lot with folks worrying so much early
on about equity stakes and sharing the
answer is it is much more important to
have a reasonable share of a success
that you know splitting up a tiny pie
doesn't matter as much as making sure
it's a huge pie be generous okay brandy
talk about inside of your business and
how you bet your own ideas without
giving away your secret sauce you found
a lot Dussehra again won this thing
partly vetting those you know crazy ones
and something that is relatively viable
and the question is so is there a
process or maybe the three top things
you okay yeah we have a very we have a
very formalized process now it used to
be it used to be you know done with a
lot of emails and whiteboards but now we
have a we have a vetting process that we
go through it's becoming more and more
formal even that even the transition
from the research team to the
development team in the spec and the
whole transfer process these are all
pretty formalized right now with an eye
to getting buy-in early getting move
we've structured a pretty
them we even have a nice little picture
about it how it all works out that I
noticed it a lot of recipients give
everybody yeah not so much but you're
really nice when you talk to somebody at
coffee yeah I know but we have a formal
process that we go through we have boxes
that we check and we keep that's where
we're diligent we keep checking those
boxes and going back and each board
meeting they go back is this still the
still the direction we want ahead are we
still this still economically viable can
we get this to market can we I don't
want to ask you for this slide but yeah
SoDo theme that the top three check
boxes do you say four gates that yeah
those probably differ from entity to
entity but ours are really are we going
to have to hire a bunch of people
because we like keeping it lean and mean
I like having an organization of a
hundred people between that's all
subsidiaries we know each other we know
each other's families we know each other
well we we ought we we were very agile
as a result of that and can we do it
highly profitably we don't like to go
into endeavors that we're going to take
four or five six years to in order to
hit profitability we like to do it early
and we really most of our businesses
surround financial models that are
transaction based okay good question a
lot of us in the room are fairly young
entrepreneurs I was wondering if you
have any suggestions particularly when
it comes to evaluating are there
particular industries or ideas that are
too big or too difficult to crack for a
young entrepreneur do you see or do you
have any advice
great idea of whether it comes from a
seven-year-old or 20 year old or a 40
year old or older I mean it's it if it's
a great idea and you can you can
articulate it and validate it and build
the management team for it go for it
take your dreams and go for it if
there's some reason why you need
relationships or something go find that
person and make them part of the team
yeah I'm trying to remember who's had
their hands up for us who's had their
hand up for a while okay good I mean
that's that's tough question to answer
without kind of specific details but I
think the fact is having the Google
example that that Dave gave us is
perfectly accurate right amid all these
big companies were perceived to be doing
a lot of a lot of innovation you know
Google came along realized those
companies were completely dead on the
inside from a technical standpoint and
then over time you know they built a
better product and they just launched it
from a consumer perspective they give
you a better answer
so people switched right it's you know
it takes time to change things but you
know they they they didn't didn't get
caught up in the perception that
everyone else did that all these other
companies would continue to innovate
indefinitely and switching costs were
low which you have yeah it's one click
away
what switchback it's equally
what about an idea that costs you a lot
of money like where do you find an
investor that is going to invest your
idea that you know you're not afraid to
take or you know disguise a
clarification so you set a service
business that requires a lot of money
yeah so you need money up front before
we even get going kind of thing okay
speak to it cuz I'm a one of the reason
I'm a fan of software is because it's so
cheap to get started you know we could
bootstrap it so the more capping you in
more risky toes different kinds of
investors are going to invest in that
kind of business I mean Green Tech in
general is a heavily capital intensive
business a lot of those things came out
of labs at universities so I mean to a
certain extent those are projects people
been working on there was some
scientific advance that they thought
they could commercialize so there's
there's been usually there's a
substantial amount of work that happens
before people are willing to pony up a
lot of money no matter what it is that's
a you better have a tremendous advantage
of the current players
22-1 attend to one advantage if you're
going to try to convince someone to give
you a lot of money up front on a concept
that so they can have to see that
there's a big prize for winning I'm
starting make sure it
are there any trading job they've got a
complementary skill someone like that or
so mistakes and picking co-founders
something like that things to watch out
for two most important things we talked
a little bit about you got to have kind
of shared mindset like you're trying to
do the same thing then you need
comparable levels of commitment and it's
you really got to know what's you you
both have to be solving for the same
thing because if you're solving for
different things forget it
it's it's going to go poorly virtually
when you have a co fund or a new idea
you're talking 24/7 I mean you could be
talking at 6:00 in the morning and 10:00
at night you better you better have
someone has the same mindset and passion
you do I guess in frightening whole
marriage it's absolutely a marriage it's
the exact same thing like the same stuff
that will go wrong in a relationship
it's yet great maybe not all the same
things yeah
Wow hey guys back row we got this is the
last one sir but IDs are easy just lay
them out there come on no we stick to
our core space which is you know if you
look at any of the businesses we've
worked in it there in the e-commerce
space and mostly transaction based and
we understand the risks associated with
doing business online and with
participating in the online community
and would be something in that space
mitigating that risk you may also want
to hit that all for you guys can take
that one if you like somebody go after
title insurance and reinventing and
refinance in real estate space tunneled
routes okay
the fact that you have to get a the
exact same policy over and over again
that is market inefficiency right there
Justin Bob weren't throwing up well I
you know I I think you look at the world
and you say there are so many
opportunities you know I have a
increasing passion for education I
suspect the next thing I do will be in
education but there are so many things
but you have to be passionate about it
you have and have fun it has to be
something you really want to do and and
not just because it can make money and
be a big business because you really
enjoy it and and don't a entrepreneur is
the most enjoyable thing in the world if
you have a real passion I think in a lot
of things that have been a lot of tools
and built on the consumer Internet - for
lack of a better word manipulate people
into doing what you want them to do I
think you can probably take a lot of
those tools and help people make the
decisions that they find difficult to
make make their lives better so I'll
give you one last idea make a list of
ten things it may start with silly ideas
and then drop them off the bottom and
keep adding your list will get better
and better
attack the top three things on the list
and see if there's anything fun - my
wrong with those ideas and so it's kind
of hypothesis driven approach and you'll
start getting better and better at this
but you got to force yourself a
discipline around kind of walking on the
world and looking for things every
single day they could be problems and
put them on that list and force rank
them every day okay guys thank you very
much can you please give the panel
[Applause]